Game of Thrones Season 6 episode 5 is
out and it is huge so let's begin at
moles town a little villager south of
the wall
Sansa confronts Littlefinger for having
given her to Ramsay Littlefinger says
he's sorry he didn't know Ramsay was so
cruel and apparently he's telling the
truth he really didn't know which is a
pretty major [ __ ] right
he gave Sansa one of his most valuable
strategic assets and someone he loves in
his own creepy way to a family that's
famous for fleeing and betraying Starks
somehow not suspecting that they'd hurt
her
Littlefinger is usually a master
manipulator but with Ramsay he made a
mistake and he admits it he presents
himself to Sansa unprotected at her
mercy to apologize so as much as
Littlefinger is using Sansa for his own
political goals he also seems to
sincerely wants answer to forgive him
he's a complicated character like this
meeting happens at moles town right
which is interesting because moles town
has the brothel where the men of the
Nights Watch come at least until the
wildling sack the town in season four
but it's in the ruins of that brothel
that Littlefinger chooses to meet Sansa
just as he meets cat in a brothel and a
Lenna in a brothel prostitution is a big
theme in Littlefinger's story in fact
the whole situation of Peter giving
Sansa to Ramsay kind of is an active
pimp eree right so much of
Littlefinger's character is rooted in a
sexual history with Lysa and Catelyn
which is tied up with these feelings of
self-worth and power and status he says
I'm not going to fight them I'm going to
[ __ ] them that is what I know that is
what I am in Littlefinger's mind sex is
deeply linked to power and control so
it's no coincidence that prostitution
and pimp eree are recurring themes in
his story anyway Littlefinger offers
Sansa the support of his knights from
the Vale but she refuses him she's
probably right not to trust him but at
the same time she and Jon and Coe really
do need more men right now those Knights
will probably end up at the Battle of
Winterfell anyway because you don't
bring an army to the north and not use
it also Littlefinger says the Tully's
led by Brendan blackfish Tully have
retaken Riverrun and may be able to
support Sansa in the north which would
be a huge help but on his way out
Littlefinger calls Jon Sansa's
half-brother not brother which seems to
make sense a doubt if she can trust
in Braavos aya trains with the wife
because hitting people with sticks is
clearly the path to becoming a great
assassin then jaqen turns up and tells
Allie the story of how the faceless men
began this was hundreds of years ago in
Valyria the empire of the original
dragon Lords who ruled most of the known
world through the power of their dragons
and their slaves in the books we're told
that slaves would mine for gold beneath
volcanic mountains called the fourteen
flames and that the mines were so hot on
the work so hard that slaves would pray
for an end to their pain so the first
faceless man was someone who killed the
slaves who suffered the most aya says he
should have killed the slave masters not
the slaves and she's told that he would
bring the gift to them as well some fans
believe this means that the faceless men
caused the doom of Valyria the massive
fiery catastrophe that suddenly
destroyed the Empire 200 years ago if
it's true that the faithless men were
behind the downfall of the original
dragon Lords they might not be a big fan
of Daenerys this new Valyrian Queen can
curring cities with her dragons maybe
the faceless men will try to kill
Daenerys is told to kill an actress so
she goes to see a play the play is a
retelling of recent events in King's
Landing the death of King Robert the
downfall of Ned the marriage of Sansa to
Tyrion it's cool to see how the public
perception of what happened is so wrong
like Ned's portrayed is an idiot who
wanted the throne when he was actually
the opposite
Tyrion plots with then betrays Ned when
that was actually Littlefinger
so as he tries to follow the rules when
she actually broke them Joffrey's a
noble prince instead of a nasty little
[ __ ] and he's kind to Sansa when he
actually threatened and beat her and
Tyrion wants to marry and sleep with
Sansa when in truth he wanted neither
but the real drama of this scene is that
ire has to relive the horrors that
happen to her family she's forced to
watch her father's execution for the
second time maybe the faceless men are
testing her here by confronting her with
memories of her family cuz to become
no.1 she'd have to let go of the people
she loves
afterwards I aspires on Lady crane the
woman she's meant to murder and she
seems nice so back at the house ie talks
as though she doesn't wanna kill crane
jack and says she's not meant to care if
she's nice she's not meant to ask
questions she's meant to blindly serve
the many-faced God the God
of death so again I is being tested will
she give up a sense of justice and
murder an innocent woman jaqen says
she's on a last chance it's
make-or-break time and hints from the
books and show suggests she's going to
leave the faceless men and it's going to
be bloody then beyond the wall bran has
a vision of the children of the forest
creating the White Walkers this would
have happened some 10,000 years ago when
humans first came to Westeros and
started a war with the children who had
been there long before eventually the
children in the first men made peace in
an agreement called the pact but this
scene seems to suggest that some time
before the pact the children created
White Walkers as a weapon for their war
against the humans at some point the
children must have lost control of the
walkers because thousands of years later
the long night happened when White
Walkers attacked and almost took over
Westeros they were stopped by the humans
and the children working together to
fight and win the war for the dawn after
the war the wall was built to keep the
walkers other they didn't make the
walkers pay for the wall this was all
thousands and thousands of years before
the story of the series begins so the
history is pretty hazy here but we do
finally know what Walkers are there like
a Frankenstein's monster an experiment
that got loose or like the robots in
Terminator weapons that turned on their
creators we don't know how the walkers
got out of the children's control but
maybe the problem was that they learned
how to make more of themselves by
converting human babies it's a problem
when you're killing machines can
self-replicate right well maybe the
problem was the whites the zombies that
walkers raised from the dead because the
thing is we saw that dragonglass was
used in the creation of the walkers
dragonglass kills walkers and the
children had lots of dragonglass so
maybe they figured they could easily
control the walkers that way but the
Wyatts these zombies aren't hurt by
dragonglass the children can't easily
stop them so maybe the walkers went
rogue when they started raising armies
of the Dead also this first white Walker
appears to be the night king the Walker
who now leads the army of the Dead which
means the night king must be like 10,000
years old so are the Walker's immortal
that might explain why there have been
thousands of years in-between their
attacks they can afford to be patient
also this child of the forest is
leaf the same child who's alive in the
present so maybe that children are also
immortal
it's weird looks in the books left says
she's only 200 years old
regardless another thing is the pattern
of stones around the tree where the
walkers are made is similar to the
pattern of corpses the walkers leave in
season 3 so it looks like the walkers
mimic the symbols used by their creators
except the walkers make them out of
corpses it really does seem that the
walkers are purely evil a weapon gone
rogue that needs to be wiped out but is
it really that simple we know at least
in the books that they have language and
culture maybe they have a society cities
or civilization in the far north they do
do a lot of killing but they're still
thinking feeling creatures look at the
unsullied they are slaves raised as
soldiers bred for war but the character
of grey worm shows us that even people
who are created to be mindless killers
can come to love and live like anyone
else it is true that every walk will
have seen so far has been a merciless
murderer but we can't assume that every
walk is like that that's racist
admittedly it doesn't look likely that
the walkers will be more than just
monsters at least in a show but maybe
let's just think about the possibility
of peace finally readers may wonder
whether this revelation about the
walkers is true for the books as well as
the show because the walkers or others
are very different in the books but as
reddit user Lucifer Lightbringer points
out there are strong hints in the books
of the children made the walkers for
example one character compares a walker
to some child snow knight which is
exactly what the walkers are if the
Warriors for the children so yeah it's
not certain but it does seem likely that
this stuff is true for the books as well
as the show at the Iron Islands the
Ironborn hold a Kingsmoot to elect their
new king
Yara talks about making the Iron Islands
great again building the largest fleet
the world's ever seen and when a man
questions her for being a woman Theon
speaks up in her support so everyone
seems on side until Euron arrives he
makes fun of Yara and Theon boldly
admits to killing his brother King
Baylon and says he'll sail to Daenerys
and Ally with her to take Westeros and
the people are convinced they may cure
on their new king this scene is better
in the books for starters Euron has more
analogy he's this charismatic swaggering
crazy scary pirate dude like some
darkest timeline version of Captain Jack
Sparrow he rocks up with his entourage
of bastards and mutes and mongrels from
all over the world he gives out chests
of gold to the Ironborn to show how
awesome he is and he has a magic horn
called dragon binder said to be able to
control dragons he's got power he's got
loot and he's got a clear plan and
that's why the Ironborn choose him
Yara or asher is also different in the
books she's got this great funny speech
using chests of pinecones and turnips
and stuff she argues for peace instead
of this vague making out Marc stuff so
the show's version is okay but the book
version is much cooler anyway
Aaron Greyjoy a priest of the drowned
God performs a drowning ritual on yer on
a neuron finds out that Theon and Asha
have run off with their best ships so
Euron says he'll hunt them down and
orders the Ironborn to build a thousand
ships as though that's something you can
do in a short time so it looks like the
Ironborn are racing to reach Daenerys to
forge a great alliance between the
Kraken and the Dragon so let all the
world beware in Vaes Dothrak Daenerys
and Jorah have a tearful reunion
Joris shows Dany his greyscale the stony
disease that slowly killing him and she
sends him off to find a cure in the
books there's no mention of a cure you
can sometimes survive the disease as a
child like Shireen did but there's no
like magic potion that'll fix it that we
know of in the show though there is a
scene where Stannis says shereen's
greyscale didn't just go away naturally
he had it cured by a bunch of masters
and healers so maybe Jorah can do
something like that another idea that's
popular at the moment is that Jorah
might do what the character Victarion
does in the books he has his wounded arm
healed by a red priest leaving it all
bloody and boned and smoking maybe Jorah
will do something similar anyway while
Jorah the explorer looks for a cure Dany
rides for marine with a massive khalasar
in marine Varys says the peace deal with
the Masters seems to be working but
Tyrion still reckons they have a bit of
a PR problem so they go and have a chat
with keen Vera the high red priest of
volantis kin vara agrees to go spread
the word in support of Daenerys because
she believes the danny's azor Ahai or
the prince that was promised the
beside savior of the world as Varys
points out Melisandre said the same
thing about Stannis and now John so the
red priests really can't seem to decide
who their chosen one is but conveyor
hits right back at Varys talking about
his castration by a sorcerer when he was
a child
viruses [ __ ] and balls were burned in
some magic flame and he remembers
hearing words coming from the fire king
vara claims to know what those words
were and who they were spoken by and
Varys perhaps understandably is really
shaken Varys was normally so cool and
collected a master of disguising his
true feelings but here we see him openly
uncertain and vulnerable just like how
we saw Littlefinger vulnerable and
exposed power structures really are
shifting this season anyway it does him
good for Danny's cause that conveyor is
on side though Tyrion is concerned that
she's so keen to burn heretics and stuff
this could be a problem especially given
that Daenerys is also in a pretty bony
mood lately right when they meet the
Dragon Queen and the red priestess might
get along like a house on fire maybe
Danny will convert tikkun Vera's red God
feeding her flame further turning her
closer to violence and blood but back
beyond the wall bran goes off and has a
vision without blood Ravens guidance
going back to the spot where he saw the
White Walkers made but much later he
sees the army of the dead and sees the
White Walkers who lead them including
the night king himself who somehow
touches brand through the vision leaving
him marked which breaks the magical
protections on blood Ravens cave and
leave them all vulnerable to the walkers
brands training under blood Ravens got
to finish up real quick now so he plugs
into the matrix and starts downloading
as much as he can before they have to
leave back at Castle black John and
Sansa and coach strategize trying to
work out which northern houses might
support them the Bolton's already have
the umbers and the Karstarks but they
could still wind manda Lee's Glover's
more monster wins Horn woods twelve
hearts and many other minor houses if
they can get all these houses together
they could stand a chance against the
Bolton's Sansa also brings up the
Tully's who could be a huge help but she
lies to hide her meeting with
Littlefinger and his offer of the
Knights from the Vale it seems like
Sansa doesn't totally trust Jon or maybe
she only lies to keep Littlefinger out
of
this either way she does give John a
fancy new coat so it seems like things
can't be too bad between them so
everyone heads off to recruit Alice
leaving Edie in charge at Castle black
John jokes about the wall falling which
is some seriously scary foreshadowing
then back beyond the wall Mira and Hodor
get packin while Brandon Bloodraven keep
green dreaming but knock-knock the
walkers are here the children try to
defend the Kade with fire grenades but
the walkers and whites get in Mira kills
a walker summer is killed by White's
blood ravens killed by the night king
lief sacrifices herself and Hodor has a
psychic walking time-travel seizure
vision of his own future death from the
past while he sacrifices himself saving
bran and Mira by holding the door and
holy [ __ ] if that's not the biggest and
bloodiest 10 minutes in Game of Thrones
since the red wedding let's process this
so Mira kills that white Walker with a
spear with a head made of dragonglass
making her the third person known to
kill a white walk along with Sam and Jon
the death of summer is so sad with Lady
Grey wind and shaggy-dog old dead ghost
is the last known surviving direwolf
though there is also a Nymeria who
ayelet loose in the river lands in
season 1 there are strong hints in the
books that she's still out there leading
a giant wolf pack so we may see her
again but that's just two of the
original six stark dire wolves left the
death of blood raven is huge because
he's one of the oldest most powerful and
knowledgeable and mysterious characters
in the series yet we never really found
out his secrets before he died
in the books we know he's a
hundred-year-old Targaryen bastard and
brother of the watch but beyond that we
really know nothing who is he how did he
come to be a psychic tree what does he
know what are his goals what exactly was
his plan for bran and what's his history
with the walkers the way the night king
looked at him it looks like they got
years old beef and leaf it is poetic
that she was killed by the monsters she
created but was she the last of her
species as far as we know the children
in that cave were the last of the
children of the forest and finally Hodor
poor sweet innocent Hodor we learned
that Hodor is the way that he is because
in a vision of the past bran warmed into
young Willis reached through his mind
such that his presence
elf would hold the door to save bran and
mirror from whites this is so tragic and
[ __ ] up on so many levels Willis was a
happy healthy kid who had his mind and
his whole life taken away from him every
word he said for the rest of his life
was a premonition of his death yet
everyone around him just thought it was
funny and did he have a choice in this
did he know all his life the way he died
and bravely continued on anyway or is he
a handicapped man being taken advantage
of
used for reasons he didn't understand to
make things worse since Hodor was killed
by whites
he'll probably be raised as a zombie
himself forced to serve even after his
death and this is all brand's fault he
messed up having that vision on his own
and as a result most of his friends are
dead and he destroyed the life of an
innocent man past present and future
Browns learning the hard way that with
great power comes great responsibility
he's gonna have a lot of guilt to deal
with and a lot of people are asking
about the whole time-travel thing and it
looks like this isn't like Back to the
Future where Marty creates alternate
future timelines by changing the past
Brandon didn't change anything
he just caused a past event which had
already happened in his timeline Hodor
already was Hodor bran just went back
and made it happen it is time travel but
it's a closed loop here it's all in one
timeline like blood Raven says the past
is written the ink is dry so it's all
like bran can you know go back to the
past and stop the walkers from ever
being made or stopped dead from ever
dying the past is written what bran and
Meera really need to worry about now is
the future because where are they going
to go what they're going to do they're
stuck in the middle of nowhere the white
sand walkers are right behind them
they've got no Howe daughter Carrie
Brown no summer to protect them no blood
Raven to guide them they're going to
need to be rescued and their Savior will
probably be this mysterious figure from
the trailer who might be John's
long-lost uncle Benjen who's been
missing beyond the wall for like five
seasons it could also be cold handsome
mysterious friendly zombie from the
books or maybe even some combination of
the two we'll see what happens whoever
rescues them bran and Meera will
probably
for the wall but if they do will the
night Kings mark on brand be a problem
the wall and blood Ravens cave both seem
to be protected by the same kind of
magic the magic of the children of the
forest what if the moment bran steps
through the wall the whole thing comes
crashing down and the walkers walk right
through poor egg can't catch a break
so that was a hell of an episode we're
now halfway through the season and with
war in the North Eyre against the
faceless men red priests in marine
pirate sailing East and every possible
[ __ ] crazy thing happening north of
the wall
not to mention King's Landing an Old
Town and Dawn it's only going to get
more intense so thank you for watching
these videos do take a lot of work to
make so if you'd like to support the
channel and get behind-the-scenes
updates stuff like that please pledge on
patreon there's a link below there's
also a link to art bio touch altar knows
that C's depiction of you rom there but
yeah thank you to all patrons supporting
this channel including sin Bobby Joe
Branden else tags box brown lauren
sinclair quaker MC and sock siendo
Cheers